Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
L'Europe est-elle submergée
par les migrants ?
Les migrations sont devenues
un sujet majeur de préoccupation
pour les Européens,
tant en ce qui concerne les Etats
que pour les instances
institutionnelles
de l'Union Européenne.
Ce qui s'est passé
récemment à Lampedusa,
avec l'afflux de migrants,
semble appelé à se répéter.
Si les nombreuses raisons invoquées
n'apparaissent pas
toujours pertinentes,
il n'en demeure pas moins
que pas plus l'Union Européenne
que ses Etats membres
n'ont de véritable politique
de l'immigration
en mesure de faire face
à l'explosion
des demandeurs d'asile.
S'il est vrai
que les vagues migratoires
se sont intensifiées
ces dernières années,
en provenance des zones de conflit
et aussi du fait de la pauvreté,
on ne peut pas dire toutefois,
au regard de l'importance
des déplacements de populations
à l'échelle de la planète,
que l'Europe est aujourd'hui
submergée par les migrants.
Mais jusqu'à quand ?
Car cela se chiffre
par centaines
de milliers de migrants
au sein d'une Europe
qui ne dispose pas
des structures d'accueil
et d'intégration suffisantes,
qui ne sait quoi faire
de ces déboutés du droit d'asile,
qui dispose
d'une police aux frontières
de l'espace Schengen, Frontex,
bien souvent débordée
par manque d'effectif
et qui fantasme sur des quotas
socio-économiques choisis
impossibles à déterminer.
A cela s'ajoutent les réticences
individuelles et collectives
vis-à-vis de populations
en provenance d'Afrique
et du Moyen-Orient,
la pression xénophobe
de l'extrême droite,
mais pas que.
Il y a le sentiment
qui se développe actuellement
de reprendre le contrôle
du peuplement national.
C'est ce qui a poussé
les pays nordiques les plus libéraux
à durcir leur législation
sur l'immigration.
Pour en parler,
je vous présente mes invités.
Juliette Méadel,
vous êtes ancienne ministre.
Vous êtes actuellement conseillère
à la Cour des comptes.
Pierre Vermeren,
vous êtes professeur
des universités,
chroniqueur au Figaro et essayiste.
Xavier Driencourt,
vous êtes diplomate,
ancien ambassadeur de France
en Algérie.
François Héran,
vous êtes démographe.
Vous êtes dans la grande école
de l'INED
et actuellement professeur
au Collège de France.
Alors, l'immigration,
les migrants,
c'est un sujet
d'absolue actualité.
Reprendre le contrôle
des flux migratoires,
est-ce un euphémisme
pour dire
"réduire drastiquement
l'immigration",
à commencer par les 140 000
demandeurs d'asile attendus
en 2023 ?
A ce sujet,
pour Emmanuel Macron,
l'Europe n'a pas à réceptionner
toute la misère du monde.
Pour le pape François,
cela relève de l'indifférence.
Pour Didier Leschi, directeur
de l'Office français des migrations,
il n'y a jamais eu en France
autant d'immigrés.
Par rapport à ce panel
d'interprétations, qui dit vrai,
Pierre Vermeren ?
-Dire qu'il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'immigration,
c'est ce que dit l'INSEE,
puisqu'ils ont récemment présenté
sur trois générations
le chiffre de 19 millions d'immigrés
et de leurs enfants, évidemment,
puisque le processus
de naturalisation
est à l'oeuvre en France.
On parle de la France, c'est ça ?
-Oui.
-Ca, c'est quand même des chiffres
tout à fait conséquents.
Le pape, je n'ai pas
de qualification pour en parler.
Ce que je sais,
c'est que l'immigration clandestine
dont il parlait
à propos de Lampedusa,
c'est un épiphénomène
à l'échelle
du phénomène migratoire
en direction de l'UE.
Ca concerne quelques dizaines
de milliers de personnes.
Le poids lourd de l'immigration
se passe de manière légale
avec l'attribution de visas
et, après, des gens qui s'installent
légalement ou illégalement
au-delà du terme de leur visa.
Voilà.
Après, le président Macron,
effectivement,
ça fait six ans maintenant
qu'il est au pouvoir,
on ne sait pas très bien
quelle est sa politique
dans le domaine mais je pense
qu'il est quand même tout à fait
représentatif
des élites françaises
qui ont fait un choix économique
il y a une trentaine d'années,
qui consiste à promouvoir
la consommation.
Je pense qu'on n'analyse pas bien
ce phénomène.
Enfin, on est restés
très bizarrement
dans le schéma
de l'immigrant travailleur.
L'immigration du travail
a été stoppée en 1975.
Elle est marginale depuis.
Maintenant, on a un immigrant
consommateur à son corps défendant,
je dirais,
puisque c'est devenu
un rouage central
dans le fonctionnement
de notre économie qui repose d'abord
sur la consommation.
Je dirais que tout ça est vrai
à la fois.
-Juliette Méadel,
comment vous vous situez par rapport
à cette trinité :
Macron, le pape, Leschi.
En riant.
-Et le Saint-Esprit ?
Je crois qu'il y a
deux choses importantes.
-Mais par rapport à ces trois...
-Je vais vous répondre
justement par rapport au pape.
D'abord, je trouve que le pape
a eu des mots attendus
de la part du Saint-Père
puisque le message...
-Oui mais Benoît XVI aurait dit
le contraire, mais bon.
-Mais c'est bien pour ça
que nous avons un pape François
tout à fait remarquable
de par sa capacité à appliquer
à sa vision politique
les principes fondamentaux
du christianisme,
qui sont quand même l'accueil
et le fait de tendre la main
aux plus misérables que soi.
Le pape François
est cohérent avec son dogme.
Maintenant,
si l'on s'en tient,
quand même,
à la mission
de l'Europe
et la mission de la France,
prenons la question de l'asile.
La Convention de Genève,
qui est un texte merveilleux, dit
que nous devons donner l'asile
à toute personne persécutée.
Il faut l'appliquer,
toute la convention
et rien que la convention.
Ces principes fondamentaux
font de l'Europe
le pays le plus attractif
du monde.
En face de ces principes
fondamentaux, il faut aussi mettre
des chiffres clairs.
Nous n'avons jamais connu
une telle pression migratoire
en Europe et en France,
même par rapport
à la crise de 2015,
qui était une crise importante.
Cette année, +83 % de flux
qui viennent du sud
vers l'Europe.
Il y a 2500 morts
dans la Méditerranée,
c'est +83 % par rapport
à l'année dernière.
Donc, il faut le dire
et il faut pas considérer
que face à cette pression
migratoire inédite,
le politique ne peut rien faire.
Je pense que le politique peut...
-On reviendra
sur cette question.
-La réponse doit être construite
sans démagogie,
sans dire que tout dépend
de la France
et des frontières intérieures
de l'espace Schengen,
et sans dire
que tout dépend de l'Europe.
Il faut une volonté partagée...
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
-Il faut assumer que nous avons
le droit de choisir
avec qui nous voulons vivre.
-François Héran,
votre trinité migratoire.
-Alors...
Oui, c'est vrai,
je le dis souvent,
on n'a jamais eu autant d'immigrés
que maintenant en France.
12 % pour la première génération.
On peut doubler si on ajoute
les enfants nés en France
d'au moins un parent immigré,
mais quand on dit
qu'il y a 31 % de la population,
selon l'INSEE et l'INED,
qui est liée à l'immigration
sur 3 générations,
ça a été complètement mal compris.
Je me souviens
de la façon dont le Figaro
a présenté le résultat.
Il y avait
deux présentations contraires.
A la conférence de presse
de l'INSEE,
Le journaliste avait compris
qu'il y avait
31 % de personnes
qui sont immigrées elles-mêmes,
enfants ou petits-enfants
d'un ou plusieurs immigrés.
Quand on regarde,
ce que citait le journaliste
du Figaro aussi d'ailleurs,
la proportion
d'adultes qui ont
leurs 4 grands-parents immigrés,
c'est seulement 5 %.
Même les immigrés du Maghreb,
ils ne sont que 20 % à avoir
leurs 4 grands-parents immigrés.
Les populations
se rapprochent.
Les unions mixtes
progressent
et les deux populations
ne se séparent pas
mais se rapprochent.
On ne le dit pas assez.
Or, l'éditorial du Figaro,
en première page, disait :
"31 % des Français liés
à l'immigration sur 3 générations.
"Où va-t-on ?
Que fait le gouvernement ?"
Il y avait
une contradiction complète
entre le journaliste
correctement informé
et l'éditorialiste,
qui était
dans son idéologie.
Ce qu'il faut ajouter aussi,
c'est que cette progression
de l'immigration depuis l'an 2000,
quand ça a vraiment démarré,
est continue, quel que soit
le président le République
en exercice.
C'est pas monsieur Macron
qui est responsable
de la montée de l'immigration,
ni l'avant-dernier président.
Sous Sarkozy,
il y a eu une légère baisse
du rythme mais ça a augmenté.
Il y a une forme de surestimation
du politique quant à ses capacités
à réguler ce phénomène
car l'immigration a augmenté
dans le monde d'environ 60 %
et on a quasi
les mêmes chiffres en Europe.
En France,
il y a une montée forte aussi,
mais qui est plutôt de 40 %
que de 60 %.
Nous ne sommes pas en pointe
dans cette progression,
qui, elle, est bien réelle.
-Vous voulez réagir,
Pierre Vermeren,
par rapport
à ce qui a été dit ?
-C'est plutôt ce que disait
Juliette Méadel
concernant la poussée migratoire
à Lampedusa.
Je vivais au Maroc
dans les années 90.
A cette époque-là, 200 000 migrants
traversaient chaque année
le détroit de Gibraltar.
La moitié était renvoyée
chez elle par la police espagnole,
mais ces flux sont très anciens.
Il y avait déjà
beaucoup de morts à l'époque.
Le jour du 11 septembre,
tout s'est arrêté.
La police marocaine a repris
le contrôle, et pendant des années,
plus un migrant n'est passé.
C'est aussi très lié
au phénomène politique.
-Le politique
peut donc faire
plein de choses.
-Sur la sainte trinité
que vous évoquiez,
je pense que chacun est
dans son rôle,
chacun est dans son couloir,
finalement.
Le pape,
comme l'a dit madame Méadel,
on pouvait rien attendre
d'autre de lui.
Il est dans son rôle.
Il aurait pu le formuler
différemment, en disant :
"Je remercie l'Europe
d'avoir fait ce qu'elle a fait
"et il faut continuer."
Là, il est allé directement
sur le fait
d'être encore plus généreux.
Le président, il est
dans son rôle de dire cela.
Quant à Didier Leschi,
c'est un grand professionnel
des questions d'immigration.
Donc...
-Vous, Xavier Driencourt,
vous étiez diplomate.
Vous avez été ambassadeur
en Algérie.
-A deux reprises, pendant huit ans.
-Voilà.
Je suis à la Cour
du droit d'asile.
-Tout à fait.
A votre avis,
le fait
que les politiques migratoires,
d'immigration,
soient à la fois
de la responsabilité
des traités européens
et également
des politiques nationales,
est-ce que c'est pas gênant
pour coordonner les deux ?
-Votre point de vue
de diplomate là-dessus.
Est-ce que c'est inconciliable ?
-C'est gênant
pour deux raisons.
D'abord, dans une Europe à 27,
on a du mal à se mettre d'accord
avec des politiques
qui sont complètement différentes,
voire divergentes.
En Estonie, leur préoccupation,
c'est l'immigration russe.
C'est la population russe
qui habite
en Estonie,
c'est pas les Africains
ou les gens du Sahel.
Deuxièmement, tout ce débat
se situe aujourd'hui
dans un contexte international
qui est ce qu'il est,
avec le Sahel,
le Maghreb, qui va mal,
et nos relations avec ces pays-là,
qui vont également mal.
Donc,
c'est normal
que la contradiction
entre une politique européenne,
qui se cherche,
et des politiques nationales,
dont la politique française,
qui est largement
tournée et implantée
en Afrique
depuis longtemps,
pose des difficultés
dans l'opinion française.
-On va rentrer donc
sur les questions d'actualité.
Les naufragés
en mer Méditerranée
entraînent
des centaines de morts.
Les pays
comme l'Italie, la Grèce,
ne veulent plus accueillir
ou pas accueillir
tous les migrants
qui se présentent.
Les pays d'origine des migrants
ne sont pas coopératifs
pour récupérer
ceux qui ont transité
sur leur pays.
Les passeurs se foutent
des réglementations.
Alors, on a une impasse
qui est politique,
sécuritaire et socio-économique,
pour restreindre
les arrivées de migrants.
Sur deux points précis,
je voudrais avoir votre avis,
François Héran.
Au sein de l'espace Schengen,
et pour en protéger l'accès,
est-ce qu'il est possible
et acceptable aujourd'hui
d'ériger des barrières
de sécurité et de surveillance,
des murs, en quelque sorte,
à la fois sur terre
et sur mer ?
-Alors, on en a déjà un :
les dizaines
et les dizaines de kilomètres
de hautes clôtures barbelées
dans le Calaisis.
Il faut y aller, il faut voir ça.
C'est très impressionnant.
Ca a pris une extension énorme.
Donc, les Anglais sous-traitent
le contrôle de leurs frontières
aux Français,
qui sont piégés
par une série d'accords.
Ca ne marche pas.
Le nombre des traversées
de "small boats",
comme disent les Anglais,
n'a cessé de progresser
alors que la défense physique,
ces clôtures sont
de plus en plus impressionnantes.
Ca ne marche pas.
On peut toujours multiplier
le nombre
de policiers,
ajouter des drones aux clôtures,
il faut se demander
pourquoi ça ne marche pas.
La France fait une politique étrange
dans le Calaisis : on fait tout
pour garder chez nous
des migrants
qui veulent aller à l'étranger.
C'est très étrange quand on y pense.
Deuxièmement, nous demandons
à l'Italie qu'elle fasse
la même chose que nous
vis-à-vis de l'Angleterre.
Les Italiens aimeraient bien
que les Tunisiens
soient aussi dociles
envers les migrants.
Ou la Libye.
C'est ce que j'écrivais
dans un éditorial hier,
l'Europe est striée
par une série de défausses,
qui vont toujours du nord au sud,
et ça ne marche pas.
Ca ne marche pas
à ces frontières.
Je connais bien le Briançonnais,
la frontière italienne.
-Ca existe pour les pays
qui sont en Europe
centrale et orientale.
-Oui.
Il faut quand même savoir
que les pays
d'Europe centrale et orientale,
la Hongrie, la Pologne,
la Slovaquie,
ne sont pas attractifs.
Ce sont des pays d'émigration
et pas d'immigration.
Ils perdent de leur population.
-Si vous prenez la Pologne,
aujourd'hui,
elle a 1,5 million d'Ukrainiens.
-Ce sont des Ukrainiens...
On se trompe toujours
à ce sujet.
Ce ne sont pas
des immigrés permanents.
-Sur ce que vous dites...
-Je termine ma phrase.
C'est de la main-d'oeuvre
provisoire.
Les Polonais n'acceptent pas
que les Ukrainiens puissent avoir
des séjours d'au moins un an,
qui en feraient
de véritables immigrés.
Quand vous regardez
la véritable durée du séjour,
il n'y a quasiment pas
d'immigré ukrainien en Pologne.
-Vous venez de dire
que les pays se défaussent
et que les murs
ne fonctionnent pas.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec la décision européenne
de faire une surveillance
beaucoup plus forte
au niveau maritime ?
Ca serait, quelque part,
un mur maritime.
-Le pacte européen
des migrations...
-Il a été récemment décidé.
-Non, non, non.
-Ah ben, ils en ont parlé.
-Vous permettez que je précise ?
Je connais très bien
cette affaire.
C'est, pour l'instant,
la Commission européenne
qui a défini
un projet provisoire,
à la grande surprise
des parlementaires.
Ca doit encore être validé
par le Parlement européen
et par le Conseil,
par l'ensemble des responsables
de gouvernement.
Pour l'instant, provisoirement,
si ce pacte est appliqué,
il y a effectivement un contrôle
aux frontières.
C'est le renforcement
du système Dublin.
Il y a un contrôle, au pays,
de première entrée,
d'une part.
Il y aurait aussi,
et c'est ce qui a été négocié
par la Commission européenne...
Chaque pays
pourrait contribuer,
non pas en prenant
sa part d'immigrés
en fonction de sa population
et de sa richesse,
comme le plan Juncker l'avait prévu,
mais en donnant une part variable.
Il pourrait accueillir
des personnes, envoyer des experts,
envoyer de l'argent,
pour accepter ou non
les migrants.
La Hongrie et la Pologne
y participeraient.
-Juliette Méadel,
par rapport
à ce qui vient d'être dit,
est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est réalisable,
ces murs,
avant que les migrants n'arrivent ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez
d'un contrôle maritime
qui serait plus étroit ?
On a appelé ça
le "mur de l'Atlantique".
Ca pourrait s'appeler
le "mur de la Méditerranée",
par exemple.
-Je pense
que non seulement
c'est réalisable,
mais c'est aussi nécessaire.
Ce qui se passe
dans le Calaisis, précisément,
ce que fait l'Etat français,
c'est qu'ils empêchent les migrants,
qui sont le fruit
de trafics organisés savamment
et de façon toujours plus lucrative
par les passeurs,
qui sont organisés
avec des filières très lucratives.
Il est plus rentable
de faire du trafic de migrants
que du trafic de drogue.
Ce que font les passeurs,
c'est qu'ils les amènent
au bord de la plage,
et puis,
juste avant de passer
vers la Manche,
ils se dépêchent...
Je l'ai vu.
-Non mais je sais très bien.
-Laissez-la parler,
s'il vous plaît.
-En 30 secondes,
ils gonflent les bateaux,
ils se précipitent
pour aller en mer.
Leur jeu, c'est d'éviter
de se faire interpeller
tant qu'ils sont sur le sable.
Pour les gendarmes,
c'est difficile.
Que font les gendarmes
et les policiers ?
Dès qu'ils prennent la mer,
ils viennent les sauver.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que tous ces hommes
risquent de mourir en mer.
Je suis quand même fière
d'appartenir à un pays où on empêche
des femmes, des enfants,
de se noyer dans la Manche.
-Il faut juger au résultat.
-Ca veut dire que la question
de la politique migratoire
et ce dans quoi
l'Etat français intervient,
c'est des conventions
internationales,
c'est aussi la protection
des plus fragiles,
et oui, ça passe
par le fait
d'ériger
des protections maritimes
pour éviter
que des hommes et des femmes
ne se noient en mer
parce que ça fait partie
de tout un système.
Dire : "On ne peut rien faire,
"il faut laisser les passeurs
faire leur trafic..."
-Je n'ai pas dit ça.
-Attendez.
-Ca heurte l'idée...
-Je vous en prie,
laissez-la intervenir.
-Juste un mot.
-Attendez.
-Ca heurte l'idée que je me fais
du rôle de l'Etat français.
-Plus on ferme
les frontières,
plus on enrichit les passeurs.
Si Mme Le Pen
arrivait au pouvoir,
les premiers à se frotter les mains
seraient les passeurs.
Ils relèveraient leurs tarifs
parce que les risques
vont augmenter.
-On peut pas dire ça...
-Pierre Vermeren, Xavier Driencourt,
c'est quand même très important,
c'est deux questions importantes.
Cet espace Schengen,
aujourd'hui,
on parle de mieux
le contrôler
par des frontières maritimes...
Terrestres
et maritimes.
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Bon, d'abord, moi, je suis pas
spécialiste de droit européen
mais je constate que certains pays
dans le monde, comme le Japon,
qui se trouve face à la plus grande
puissance démographique mondiale,
n'a pas d'immigrant.
Il y a plus de Chinois
en France qu'au Japon.
Si j'étais chinois,
je migrerais au Japon.
-C'est une erreur.
-Laissez-le parler !
Ne soyez pas juge
des propos de chacun !
-Il faut que ce soit un débat.
Si ce n'est pas un débat...
-Laissez-le s'exprimer !
-Il y a une immigration
qui est pas très ancienne
et qui est pas très connue.
Désolé,
j'ai enseigné
pendant des années
les cours d'histoire
du Japon.
Le Japon est...
Ils parlent en même temps.
-Ca se répète d'année en année.
C'est de l'immigration dissimulée
sous la forme de stages.
-Et ça concerne davantage
les Coréens
que les Chinois.
On pourrait imaginer
100 millions d'immigrants
chinois ou asiatiques au Japon.
C'est pas le cas.
Il devrait y avoir ça.
C'est le pays le plus riche
de l'Asie.
Et du monde.
Il y a quelques années.
C'est plus le cas.
Ils ont notre niveau de vie.
Ils sont comme nous,
en termes de niveau de vie.
Ils sont face
à des masses démographiques.
Deux pays
de 1,5 milliards d'habitants.
Ils n'ont pas d'immigration.
Ce sont des îles, j'en conviens.
Mais l'Europe aussi est une île.
La population n'arrive pas
par la Russie.
Une presqu'île, disons.
C'est le premier point.
Le deuxième point :
il faut bien réaliser
que le produit
de ces migrations,
ce sont soit des Etats faillis.
Les Etats faillis,
c'est pas ce qui manque
au sud de la Méditerranée.
Les Soudan.
Vous avez l'Ethiopie en guerre.
Vous avez la Tunisie.
Ce n'est pas un Etat failli
mais très affaibli.
Vous avez la Libye,
un Etat failli.
Vous avez le Mali, le Niger, etc.
Ces Etats ne vont pas
se ressaisir
et prendre le contrôle
de leur territoire,
que je sache.
Or, vous savez,
si on parle
en démographie générale,
j'ai calculé,
vous avez
52 naissances en Afrique
pour 1 naissance en France.
Vous avez
un déséquilibre intercontinental.
Au niveau de l'UE,
c'est un peu plus.
Ca doit être 8 naissances,
toute l'Europe,
pour 52 en Afrique.
Un déséquilibre considérable.
Vous avez des Etats qui
ne satisfont pas leur population.
On peut en parler des heures.
Vous avez donc des masses
de jeunes gens,
la moyenne d'âge est très jeune...
60 à 80 % des Africains
ont moins de 25 ans.
C'est à cet âge-là qu'on part,
c'est pas à 70 ans.
Donc, à cet âge-là,
on a un milliard d'habitants
qui ne veulent pas tous partir,
mais ça se compte
en dizaine de millions de gens
qui veulent partir.
Donc, soit, on dit :
"Bah, OK, on a les moyens
de les intégrer,
"et même si on les a pas,
on y va."
Soit, effectivement,
il faut
contrôler
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Si vous voulez, je le disais,
il y a d'autres exemples
dans le monde
de cette résistance complexe.
Mais surtout, sinon,
on change...
Je dirais...
On change
de modèle, d'économie,
de pays, de langue,
de civilisation...
-Ouais, alors...
J'aimerais avoir votre point de vue.
Vous avez été ambassadeur
en Algérie.
On a des problèmes aujourd'hui
avec la Tunisie.
Comme on en a eu avec la Turquie.
En voulant sous-traiter
l'immigration...
Mais en même temps,
les propositions
affluent de partout
en disant
qu'il faut contrôler
ces migrants avant
qu'ils atterrissent en Europe.
Ca vous paraît gérable ?
Réalisable ?
-Je vais revenir sur le point
précédent, si vous me permettez.
J'ai pas mal évolué là-dessus
par ma pratique de ces questions.
Par les 8 années passées
en Algérie.
Par, aujourd'hui, la pratique
de la Cour du droit d'asile
où je siège...
Comme tout diplomate,
je dirais, j'étais
ou je suis plutôt
pro-européen,
assez libéral, etc.
Mais je pense
aujourd'hui
qu'on pourra pas s'empêcher
de remettre en cause
une bonne partie de nos acquis,
ou de notre système...
Même Schengen, vous en parliez.
Je pense que Schengen
correspondait à une époque,
le marché unique,
la libre circulation
des produits
et des hommes...
Aujourd'hui, dans le contexte
dans lequel nous sommes,
on referait pas Schengen,
en clair.
Je pense que l'Europe
n'échappera pas
à une remise en cause
d'un certain nombre de principes.
Je pense également
que ce n'est pas
uniquement en bloquant
la Tunisie,
ou les Afghans vers
la Grande-Bretagne,
que ça marchera.
Je crois qu'on ne pourra pas
non plus
contrôler l'immigration.
Ce n'est pas possible.
Il faut un patchwork de mesures.
Des mesures diplomatiques,
des mesures internationales,
réglementaires...
Des mesures législatives.
Ce n'est pas la loi prochaine
qui va régler le problème.
Ne soyons pas naïfs.
Des mesures sociales...
Il y aura un ensemble
de mesures que l'Europe,
la France,
notamment,
doit penser.
-Ce qui est d'ailleurs
le cas, sur Schengen,
car depuis 2015,
à cause de la menace terroriste,
on est revenus...
Les usages ont rétabli
le contrôle aux frontières
intérieures de la zone.
-Je pense que la libre circulation
à l'intérieur de l'espace Schengen
pour les non-Européens,
c'est une aberration.
-Là-dessus...
Sur ce point...
-Je reconnais
que je peux choquer
là-dessus.
-Je suis assez d'accord
avec monsieur.
A savoir que c'est un patchwork
de mesures qui sera nécessaire.
Notre politique des murs va
dans le mur, si j'ose dire.
Elle s'est avérée inefficace.
Que ce soit à la frontière
franco-italienne,
franco-britannique,
ou à la frontière basque...
Plus on multiplie les policiers,
plus les passages augmentent.
Ce qui montre qu'il faut...
Il faut réfléchir à des mesures.
C'est dur.
C'est plus simple de doubler
le nombre de gendarmes.
Voilà.
Ensuite, effectivement,
il y a tout
le problème diplomatique.
C'est-à-dire
que les pays qui génèrent
80 % des demandeurs d'asile,
les demandeurs de refuge,
on pourrait dire,
dans le monde,
c'est 5, 6, 7 pays, hein.
Un tout petit nombre de pays.
C'est concentré.
On a cité le Soudan...
Regardez, le pays le plus représenté
parmi les gens qui se sont présentés
à Lampedusa...
-Afghanistan.
-C'est la Guinée.
C'est la Guinée.
-Non.
-Entre parenthèses,
c'est le seul pays à avoir noté
non en 1958 à la communauté.
-Franchement, je pense pas
que ça ait un rapport.
Ca n'a pas de rapport.
En réalité,
en Guinée, il y a deux ans,
il y eu un coup d'Etat.
Une violence extrême.
Il y a un très grand nombre
de violences commises
par des hommes en uniforme.
Les gens cherchent pas
l'eldorado.
Ils cherchent juste
à pouvoir développer
un projet simple
et avoir
un minimum de sécurité.
-Vous constatez
qu'au niveau
des pays européens,
y compris
les plus démocratiques,
comme les pays nordiques,
il y a une volonté,
aujourd'hui, des peuples,
des Etats,
des gouvernants,
de restreindre
l'immigration.
Vous contestez ça ?
-Absolument pas.
J'en ai parlé très souvent.
Dans mes cours, dans mes tribunes.
J'ai cité récemment
le cas de la Suède.
La Suède était longtemps
le premier pays européen
qui répondait aux demandes du HCR,
le Haut Commissariat aux réfugiés.
Pour accueillir les personnes
que personne ne voulait.
Et ceci,
dans les années
2012, 2013, 2014.
Avant la crise des migrants.
Ils ont été lassés de jouer
les bon élèves seuls,
et se sont arrêtés,
non pas en 2015 comme je l'ai écrit,
il y a une coquille, mais en 2017.
Avant même les Allemands,
l'accord des Allemands,
ils ont cessé.
Il faut une juste répartition
de l'effort, de la charge,
entre les pays européens.
-Il faut dire
qu'ils ont une politique migratoire
beaucoup plus efficace que la nôtre.
Ils ont accueilli
plus en proportion.
Ils en ont un million
sur une population
de 10-11 millions.
Ils mettent de l'argent
sur l'apprentissage de la langue,
sur l'emploi...
Les migrants ont
le droit de travailler.
Et un logement.
-Ce sont des éléments importants.
Vous avez raison d'insister dessus.
Ce sont des éléments importants.
Il y a aussi le cas du Danemark.
Il sert de modèle à certains.
Une social-démocratie
qui donne des gages
à l'extrême-droite.
Le problème du Danemark
est que c'est un pays
qui a un seul grand
voisin terrestre,
l'Allemagne,
14 fois plus peuplé,
donc c'est une politique
de tire-au-flanc.
De "free rider",
comme disent
les économistes.
Ils peuvent se permettre
de refuser les indésirables.
L'Allemagne les accepte.
C'est ce que fait le Canada.
Il peut être extrêmement
sélectif,
car les Etats-Unis,
10 fois plus peuplés,
accueillent les Hispaniques
dont le Canada ne veut pas.
Des politiques qui ne sont pas
généralisables,
qui reposent
sur une rampe de situation,
sur un puissant voisin
beaucoup plus intégrateur,
par définition,
on peut pas les importer
dans un grand pays comme la France.
-Je vous soumets cette citation
de Jean-Louis Borloo.
"Reprendre le contrôle
du peuplement
"est quelque chose
"qui peut être partagé."
Vous voyez ?
Le contrôle du peuplement.
D'après
la Banque mondiale,
l'immigration serait
un moteur de prospérité
et de développement.
C'est d'autant plus vrai
que nous manquons
de travailleurs
dans de nombreux secteurs
de l'économie.
Peut-on procéder
à des quotas choisis ?
Faut-il pour autant régulariser
les immigrés
travaillant dans les secteurs
dits en tension.
Cela dit,
alors
que près de 400 000 immigrés
en France,
actuellement,
en situation régulière,
sont en chômage.
Pierre Vermeren.
-Ce sont des choix politiques.
Si vous voulez,
on a un problème
en médecine,
en France.
On manque de médecins,
d'infirmières, etc.
On en a quand même deux à trois fois
plus qu'en Afrique.
Pour les pays les plus
avancés d'Afrique,
les pays du Maghreb.
Or, pour combler,
et pour des raisons
légitimes,
on a fait venir,
l'année dernière,
plusieurs milliers
de médecins d'Algérie.
Il y a 15 000 ou un peu plus
médecins marocains
qui exercent en France.
Et donc, si vous voulez,
en aggravant la situation
de la santé dans ces pays,
on a...
Et donc, c'est des pays,
il faut réaliser,
où la Sécurité sociale
est modeste.
Elle est réservée aux fonctionnaires
et aux cadres des grandes sociétés.
L'essentiel,
c'est la médecine publique.
Si la médecine publique,
déjà deux à trois fois
bien moins dotée
la nôtre,
en spécialistes...
Pour les infirmières,
les équipements,
c'est bien moindre.
Et qu'on déshabille les hôpitaux
du Maghreb
à notre profit...
On aggrave la situation
et on intensifie,
de ce fait, le départ,
et la volonté de partir,
de populations
qui veulent vivre
normalement...
Parmi les choses
qui permettent ça,
si on est malade,
on espère
être soigné.
C'est un choix politique.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est...
Les élites du Maghreb,
très souvent,
viennent se faire soigner en Europe.
Lorsqu'elles en ont
les moyens.
Elles ont davantage confiance
en la médecine qui est la nôtre.
Ma femme a accouché au Maroc,
et tout le monde lui a dit :
"Drôle d'idée d'accoucher
au Maroc et pas en France !"
Ca, c'est une expérience vécue.
Mais pour les classes populaires,
qui n'ont aucune chance
de se faire soigner
ailleurs,
dans des bonnes conditions,
à ce moment,
l'immigration est
une vraie solution.
Il faut être cohérent.
Il serait pas
plus simple d'ouvrir
les vannes de la formation
en médecine ?
On a pas mis fin
au numerus clausus
en réalité,
on l'a fait
dans de toutes petites proportions.
On est tributaires de médecins
formés à l'étranger.
Dans des pays
où la médecine est très faible.
C'est un choix.
-Pour ces secteurs
en tension,
qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Deux leviers dans
la politique migratoire.
Le stock,
ceux qui sont là,
et puis il y a le flux.
Les 600 000 clandestins en France,
dont on dit
qu'ils pourraient résoudre
nos problématiques
de métiers en tension,
ces 600 000, ils sont là,
ils sont pour beaucoup
ni expulsables,
ni régularisables,
et c'est la circulaire Valls
qui s'applique.
Au terme de 5 ans
de travail
dans des conditions régulières,
on peut les régulariser.
Oui, il faut les régulariser,
en appliquant les textes factuels.
Les préfets peuvent,
grâce à la circulaire Valls,
en régulariser.
Ils le font à hauteur
de 100 000 par an.
Oui, il faut les régulariser.
Pourquoi ?
On les reconduira pas
à la frontière.
Vous connaissez
les problématiques
de reconduites à la frontière.
C'est cher,
et pas opérationnel.
Et oui, il se trouve
qu'ils travaillent,
qu'ils répondent
à un besoin économique.
Au nom de quoi
on se priverait
de la valeur ajoutée ?
C'est pour le stock.
Et pour le flux,
ça ne vaut,
de dire ça,
qu'il faut régulariser,
que si vous êtes clair
sur vos conditions de régularisation
des flux entrants.
C'est là qu'il faut tout changer.
Il faut être beaucoup plus
opérationnel sur qui on accueille
et dans quelles conditions.
Et aussi dans quelles
proportions.
Il faut ce message d'humanité
sur la régularisation,
et aussi de fermeté
sur la maîtrise
et avec de l'humilité.
Vous avez raison, on ne résoudra pas
les flux, on ne contrôlera pas tout.
Il faut que la nation
démocratique...
C'est un choix entre nous,
entre citoyens,
il faut qu'on dise
ce qu'on est prêts à faire.
Et comment on peut accueillir
ceux qui arrivent.
On n'est pas capables
de traiter
avec humanité
les immigrés qui sont
sur notre sol,
et qui,
pour beaucoup,
sont discriminés,
et qui n'ont pas accès
au minimum
de service public.
-Sur la circulaire Valls,
il est important de rappeler
qu'elle n'a pas
de valeur contraignante.
On peut pas en faire état
devant les tribunaux.
C'est juste des recommandations
aux préfets.
-Ca n'a que la valeur
d'une circulaire.
-"Appliquez tel ou tel critère."
Le Conseil d'Etat a fait un rapport
sur le droit flexible.
Il a examiné
la circulaire.
Il s'est réjoui en disant
que les préfets
devront harmoniser
les critères.
C'est pas ce qui se passe.
Il y a eu des rapports
de la Cour des comptes,
à la LOLF de l'an dernier,
qui montrent qu'un tiers
des préfets n'appliquent pas
la circulaire Valls.
Un tiers des préfets
considèrent que, même si
un dossier a été remis
en bonne forme,
et qu'il n'y a pas de traitement,
ils n'ont pas les moyens.
L'emploi des préfectures,
c'est un rapport
de la Cour des comptes,
a diminué de 14 % en 10 ans.
Les Bureaux du séjour et de l'asile
ont été très touchés.
Les préfets,
pas nécessairement par idéologie,
simplement sous contrainte,
disent à leurs agents
de donner
la priorité au renouvellement
du titre de séjour
et pas à l'admission
au séjour,
c'est-à-dire
à la régularisation.
On a une rupture d'égalité
entre les territoires
qui est considérable.
Et donc, la loi Darmanin,
ce qu'elle propose,
le volet travail,
c'est d'introduire
les critères
de la circulaire Valls
dans la loi.
Faire en sorte
que ce soit plus un examen
au cas par cas qui dépendrait
du bon vouloir de l'employeur
et du bon vouloir du préfet,
mais que ce soit
un examen sur critères.
Il faut les définir.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord
sur l'idée qu'il faut définir
rigoureusement ces critères
car il faut stabiliser
les populations.
A ce moment,
l'employeur,
par exemple, ne pourra plus
s'opposer à la régularisation,
et le préfet ne sera pas
mis devant
des choix impossibles.
-Vous êtes en faveur
de la régularisation des métiers
en tension ?
-J'y suis favorable
parce que je pense
que la philosophie
zéro régularisation est
tout aussi irréaliste
que la philosophie zéro immigration.
Si vous voulez,
le statut de la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine
a été marqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel, en 2013.
C'est une contribution
à l'ordre public.
Très bien.
Mais si vous faites
une philosophie zéro régularisation
et que vous la mettez en pratique,
le nombre des irréguliers
augmentera.
Ils parlent en même temps.
-Une forme de désordre.
-Sur les quotas.
On emploie cette formule :
"On va mettre en place
"une politique de quotas."
Il faut savoir exactement
ce que ça veut dire.
C'est-à-dire...
Ca va être des quotas,
effectivement,
par catégories
socio-professionnelles
ou par groupes familiaux,
ou autres.
Ca veut dire
qu'on a besoin
de 20 000 médecins,
cette année,
le 21 000e qui se présente,
on lui dira non ?
D'attendre son tour ?
C'est extrêmement compliqué
à mettre en oeuvre
une politique de quotas.
Les Américains le font
avec un système de points.
Le Canada aussi.
Est-ce que,
dans une Europe
dont la politique migratoire
est largement une politique
communautaire européenne,
on est capables de mettre en place
une politique de quotas ?
-Je vais vous donner la parole
mais j'ajoute
un point que vous préciserez.
A propos de cette régularisation
pour les métiers en tension,
est-ce qu'à votre avis,
c'est une poudre aux yeux
électorale et politique
au regard
de la situation actuelle,
où il y a des centaines
de milliers d'immigrés,
en situation régulière,
qui sont au chômage,
qu'on a connu des violences
dans les banlieues,
et que ces jeunes
ne sont pas véritablement
intégrés ?
Est-ce que par rapport à ça,
si vous voulez, on essaye de...
Comment dire ?
De faire du "en même temps" ?
-Non, on est dans une situation
économique catastrophique.
C'est vrai que le débat juridique
est découplé.
Juridique et du droit du travail.
Il est découplé
de la situation économique.
C'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure.
Dans des proportions
considérables.
Par rapport à l'Allemagne,
on a un taux d'emploi
ridicule, en réalité.
Ca ne concerne pas que les immigrés.
Il y a 400 000 immigrés légaux
au chômage.
En réalité,
le taux d'emploi des Français
et des populations immigrées,
en particulier
de certaines régions,
est très faible.
Il y a des réservoirs
de travail.
Mais il y a un manque de travail.
Pourquoi le patronat
s'accroche
à cette catégorie
des métiers en tension ?
Il faut accepter des gens
très peu payés
dans des métiers durs,
dans des villes chères.
Si vous voulez, effectivement,
c'est un beau cadeau qu'on fait
d'avoir besoin de gens
qui viennent des pays
les plus misérables du monde,
pour leur donner les travaux
pénibles,
logés dans des foyers
sans aucun confort,
à des horaires
parfaitement
nocturnes,
le plus souvent,
ou commençant
très tôt le matin.
Ca supposerait de réfléchir
à la question du logement !
Pourquoi des millions de personnes
ne travaillent pas ?
Pourquoi ils ne viennent pas
dans les métropoles ?
Parce que le logement
y est inabordable.
On dit que les banques
ne prêtent plus
et que la construction est
en difficulté,
et en même temps,
500 000 personnes rentrent
chaque année en France.
Vous créez les conditions
de l'inflation sur les logements.
C'est pour ça que
la question juridique,
dans un Etat de droit,
elle est centrale.
Si on pose la question économique
sur la table,
on se demande ce que c'est
que cette histoire
de métiers en tension,
de 600 000 personnes,
dans un pays où il manque
10 millions d'emplois ?
Donc, la...
La question économique,
et notamment
de la production,
est centrale.
Si les gens ne travaillent pas
en France,
alors qu'ils sont là,
et qu'il y a du travail,
peut-être
que le problème est ailleurs.
Il est peut-être culturel,
dans le logement,
dans beaucoup de choses
mais on pourrait
réfléchir comme ça.
-Xavier Driencourt,
vous avez choqué
en publiant un livre
sur vos mémoires
en Algérie.
-C'est pas des mémoires.
C'est une photographie
de l'Algérie.
-Vous allez voir
où je veux
en venir.
Euh...
La voie du référendum
pour traiter de l'immigration,
est-ce qu'elle vous paraît
souhaitable ?
Puisqu'elle a été évoquée
également par Emmanuel Macron,
mais il faudrait modifier
la Constitution...
En même temps,
je voulais vous poser
cette question.
Vous avez proposé
de dénoncer
le traité signé avec l'Algérie
en 68 qui facilite
l'entrée sur le territoire français
de travailleurs algériens
accompagnés
de leur famille.
Est-ce que vous persistez
dans vos intentions
et abordez à la fois
la question référendaire
et la question de l'Algérie ?
-Sur l'accord, j'ai été clair.
J'ai publié,
non seulement,
dans mon livre,
mais aussi une note
sur la question
de l'accord franco-algérien
en disant qu'il fallait
le renégocier.
On a tenté à plusieurs reprises
mais on a rien obtenu.
Avec un délai
ou un ultimatum
pour dire aux Algériens :
"On remet les choses à plat
sur la table
"et puis si on n'y arrive pas,
"on le dénoncera."
-Qu'est-ce qui va pas
dans cet accord ?
Pourquoi le dénoncer ?
-Bah, cet accord,
il est dépassé.
Et les traités internationaux
sont supérieurs à la loi.
Ils ont une valeur
constitutionnelle,
juridique, supérieure
à la loi.
A la loi française.
-L'immigration
est une question...
-Les Algériens échappent
à la loi française.
En matière d'immigration.
Vous verrez,
dans le projet de loi
qui va paraître,
il y aura un article
disant
que ces dispositions
s'appliquent
aux pays étrangers,
sauf aux Algériens,
qui sont régis
par l'accord de 1968.
Sur un référendum,
il faut pas poser
une question
sur être pour ou contre
l'immigration,
mais il faut avoir quelques...
Quelques...
Encore une fois,
des mesures précises,
d'ordre juridique,
d'ordre diplomatique,
d'ordre...
-C'est un peu...
Ils parlent tous en même temps.
-Ca doit être un QCM.
-Comment...
On a multiplié les lois.
Depuis 93, 21 lois, déjà,
sur l'immigration.
Ces lois sont postérieures
à l'accord avec l'Algérie,
et ne s'appliquent pas.
C'était des lois...
-Vous êtes favorable
à ce qu'on revienne
sur cette loi ?
-C'est sans incidence importante.
Non, non, mais attendez.
Je développe.
Ce sont des lois qui ont
essentiellement ciblé
l'immigration
familiale,
qui ont lutté contre
le mariage gris,
le mariage blanc,
qui ont imposé
la possibilité,
rarement appliquée,
car c'est pas applicable,
pour les mères, de vérifier
la réalité de la vie maritale.
Etc.
Toutes ces choses
qui ont été rajoutées,
bétonnées
par les lois successives,
ne s'appliquent pas
aux Algériens.
C'est pas que l'accord de 68.
Il a été renégocié
dans les années 80
et c'est la version
des années 80-84,
je sais plus...
-Le socle, c'est 68.
-Votre point de vue, là-dessus ?
Vous êtes favorable
à ce qu'on revienne dessus ?
-C'est pas fondamental.
-En disant ça...
-Je suis favorable
à ce que la loi soit
la même pour tous,
sur le territoire français,
favorable au fait
que la Cour nationale
du droit d'asile
soit davantage égalitaire.
C'est bien.
L'égalité, on y est tous attachés.
Les exceptions,
les dérogations,
comme à Mayotte,
en Guyane,
tout cela,
ça devrait disparaître.
Après, euh, voilà...
Je pense pas que le coeur
du problème soit là.
-La voie
référendaire,
par rapport à l'immigration.
C'est un tabou
qu'on franchit ?
-Je...
Je pense que c'est quand même
un peu le miroir aux alouettes.
Une grande partie du droit
en matière migratoire,
c'est du droit européen.
C'est une façon
de se défausser
à mauvais escient
sur le citoyen français
en lui faisant croire
qu'il aura les manettes
pour gérer une politique migratoire
dont on voit qu'elle échoue,
principalement en Italie,
faute d'accord
entre les pays européens,
pour se répartir
la charge migratoire.
C'est un peu une manière
un peu hypocrite et un peu facile
de dire :
"On va s'en remettre
"au citoyen français
à qui il va falloir..."
-Pour le référendum ?
-Bien sûr.
A qui on expliquera,
le référendum passé,
que les trois quarts
des questions
sur lesquelles
il a été interrogé,
c'est pas nous,
c'est l'Europe,
et nos partenaires
européens veulent pas.
Aujourd'hui, les pays
les plus assaillis en termes
de demandes d'asile,
c'est la France,
l'Angleterre,
l'Italie
et l'Espagne.
Il se trouve que la charge
migratoire,
certains pays comme le Danemark
refusent d'en prendre leur part
alors que ce qu'il faudrait,
c'est remettre au pot
toutes les demandes
et les partager en Europe.
Il y en a plein qui n'ont
aucune envie de prendre
leur part au jeu
et qui laissent...
Madame Meloni se plante.
Preuve, pour le RN,
que les solutions démagogiques
et toutes faites ne marchent pas.
Même l'extrême-droite
en Italie s'en sort pas.
Il faut un travail européen
pour répartir
la charge et ne certainement pas
demander au pauvre citoyen français
de décider alors que la France seule
n'y arrivera pas.
-Vous êtes pas favorable.
-Je crois que le référendum
est une solution illusoire.
On trompe les gens
en leur faisant croire...
-C'est prévu
dans la Constitution.
-Non.
-Dans la Ve République,
c'est prévu.
-Pas sur tous les sujets.
-Ca peut marcher ?
Il faut savoir quelle question...
Ce sera une question binaire,
oui, non,
alors que c'est compliqué.
Laissons ça de côté.
Supposons que le référendum
soit voté
et que les solutions radicales
soient appliquées,
que M. Ciotti, M. Zemmour
arrivent au pouvoir, etc.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Ils vont stopper l'immigration ?
Inverser les flux ?
Ils parlent en même temps.
Si la méthode Meloni
ne marche pas,
la méthode Salvini,
consistant à renvoyer
les bateaux...
On va les couler ?
Il y a deux solutions illusoires :
l'appel direct au peuple.
Qui ne réglera rien.
Et le côté
"On va être ferme. Fermement ferme.
Les autres l'ont pas été.
"Pasqua,
Sarkozy,
"ils étaient pas fermes,
nous, on le sera."
Ce sera deux illusions.
-Je voudrais
un mot...
-Je suis frappé
par l'évolution des points de vue
de gens comme Jacques Attali,
Manuel Valls...
Bernard Kouchner...
Ils sont quand même des docteurs
de... De la grande foi...
Libérale... Européenne...
Ils ont quand même changé
sensiblement leur point de vue.
-Je suis d'accord.
-Sur cette question,
on peut pas se contenter
de mettre des rustines...
-Je juge
aux résultats !
Je regarde les faits.
Ca marche ou pas ?
Ca ne marche pas,
ça ne marche pas.
Peu importe leur avis.
-Si vous le permettez,
on va terminer
cette émission
sur la question
politique.
Chacun dira
ce qu'il en pense.
Depuis quelques années,
voire quelques décennies,
la politique française,
et la politique
de très nombreux pays,
en Europe centrale,
en Europe orientale,
en Europe de l'Ouest,
sont parasitées
par la question migratoire
et le chantage
qu'elle peut engendrer.
Je voudrais que vous me disiez
chacun brièvement
si cette question est agitée
comme un chiffon rouge
pour éviter
l'extrême droite.
Est-ce que ça vous paraît
réaliste et fondé ?
Est-ce que les choses
sont complètement
imbriquées ?
C'est-à-dire,
l'immigration
engendrant
la venue
de l'extrême droite ?
Très peu de temps.
Pierre Vermeren.
-C'est pas une question
de politique intérieure !
Il faudrait avoir
un Etat, ou des Etats...
Si l'Europe existait,
ce serait mieux.
Si on était pas endettés,
on déciderait mais c'est pas le cas.
A un moment,
on a des interlocuteurs au sud.
La réponse,
elle est au sud.
Quand les Allemands ont voulu
arrêter la vague migratoire,
ils ont fait un chèque
de cinq milliards aux Turcs.
Ca a bloqué l'immigration
en provenance de Turquie
qui voulait se débarrasser
des Syriens sur son sol.
Ils cherchent toujours
à le faire, d'ailleurs !
Quand Kadhafi, Ben Ali,
le gouvernement algérien,
Bouteflika,
et le Maroc, l'ont décidé,
à certains moments,
les flux migratoires
étaient taris.
A partir du moment
où vous avez des Etats
qui jouent
le rapport de force,
soit parce qu'on est allés
les détruire, la Libye,
soit parce qu'ils sont
très faibles,
et qu'il y a la mafia...
Le rôle de la mafia italienne.
Elle a un rôle considérable.
Comme la mafia
albanaise ou turque.
-Des mafias !
-Les mafias jouent un rôle central.
Elles gagnent des milliards.
Ce qui fait qu'on n'a pas
les populations
les plus déshéritées.
Même s'ils viennent
des pays pauvres,
ils payent entre 5000
et 10 000 euros pour venir.
Des sommes considérables.
Les familles se cotisent
en grand nombre, etc.
Ca devient un enjeu
crucial pour eux,
certes.
Il faut s'entendre
avec ces pays.
Il faut savoir
ce qu'ils veulent.
quel est leur objectif.
Et le négocier.
Si on considère
que c'est comme la pluie,
on peut pas l'empêcher.
On peut empêcher
l'immigration
mais il faut aller
à la source.
-Il nous reste peu de temps.
-La question migratoire est,
ou a été, instrumentalisée
en politique
intérieure française.
La question migratoire,
elle est instrumentalisée
par certains pays.
Le Maroc,
la Tunisie,
l'Algérie,
etc.
Ensuite, on ne peut nier
que c'est un sujet majeur
en France
et en Europe.
-Je vous donne la parole.
François Héran ?
-Les vrais et grands problèmes
de notre société,
c'est pas celui-là.
C'est le changement climatique,
c'est l'inflation...
C'est la guerre en Ukraine.
C'est les superpuissances...
C'est les régimes illibéraux.
Et enfin...
Les Français eux-mêmes
ne pensent pas
que l'immigration
soit un problème crucial.
-Merci.
Juliette Méadel ?
-Ce n'est pas l'immigration
qui fait monter le RN.
C'est la crise sociale,
économique, écologique,
qui conduit certains à désigner
un bouc-émissaire,
avec l'étranger.
Si nous étions capables de résoudre
l'état dramatique des hôpitaux,
l'accès à l'école,
la crise du pouvoir d'achat,
la pauvreté et l'augmentation
des inégalités sociales,
nous n'aurions pas la menace
de l'extrême droite.
-C'est votre point de vue.
Ecoutez.
Il me reste à présenter
une bibliographie.
Juliette Méadel,
vous avez publié
"Un impérieux besoin d'agir".
En deux mots, c'est quoi ?
-Un livre témoignage
de mon parcours
de militante,
de ma participation
au gouvernement,
et des propositions.
Je veux qu'on arrive
à réhabiliter l'idée
que l'Etat peut beaucoup.
C'est l'une des fiertés
de notre pays.
Dans une perspective
de solidarité,
et de République forte.
-Voilà.
Pierre Vermeren, "Histoire
de l'Algérie contemporaine",
aux éditions
du Nouveau monde.
Avec l'Algérie,
ça change
sans changer ?
-Oui, ce que j'ai voulu faire,
c'est un livre sur l'Algérie
jusqu'à nos jours.
Ca ne s'arrête pas en 62.
On serait avisés de s'intéresser
à ce qui se passe dans ce pays.
François Héran,
"Migrations et sociétés",
publié à la fois chez Fayard
et le Collège de France.
C'est votre leçon inaugurale.
-De 2018. 2017.
-Votre dernier livre...
-"Immigration : le grand déni".
Il consiste à constater
qu'un certain nombre d'acteurs
dans le débat public
grossissent l'immigration
pour pouvoir justifier
de la réduire drastiquement.
C'est ce paradoxe
que je décris.
-Il n'y a pas un accord
sur les chiffres, aujourd'hui ?
On arrive à...
-On a, maintenant,
des chiffres de meilleure qualité,
entre l'OCDE, Eurostat...
-Pour prendre
l'INSEE, l'INED...
-On a une qualité...
C'est ça que je déplore.
Effectivement,
dans le débat public,
il y a très peu d'attention
aux faits,
et beaucoup plus
de démagogie
que de pédagogie.
-"L'énigme algérienne,
chroniques d'une ambassade à Alger",
Xavier Driencourt.
-C'est un retour d'expérience
sur les deux ambassades
que j'ai...
Que j'ai faites en Algérie.
-Vous restez attaché à l'Algérie ?
-Oui.
-Voilà.
-C'est un pays énigmatique.
-Qui vous reste
énigmatique ?
-Même après 8 ans
en Algérie, oui !
Je crois qu'après 132 années,
pour beaucoup de Français,
c'est un pays énigmatique.
-C'est intéressant.
-Bah, écoutez,
merci madame,
merci messieurs
d'avoir animé à mes côtés
cette émission,
qui n'est pas simple,
car la question migratoire,
nous en avons pour longtemps.
Merci à l'équipe
de LCP, qui réalise
cette émission.
Euh...
Il me reste
à vous soumettre cette pensée
de Thibault de Montbrial :
"Nous avons importé
sur notre territoire
"les guerres ethniques
"du monde entier."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA